what's your opinion on the
mass surveillance
that
is um reported to have been conducted by
the
nsa
we talked about ethics are you troubled
by the
from a public perception
the
unethical nature of mass surveillance of
especially american citizens
this is a topic that i never get tired
of talking about but it's very rare that
anyone ever really agrees with me
just so you know
so i see where you're well i think
there's a nuanced thing here maybe we'll
find some agreement the truth is that
the
american experience after 9 11
is nothing like the american experience
now so all the terminology all the all
this talk about
privacy and privacy laws and mass
surveillance and all this other stuff it
was a completely different time then and
that's not to say it was an excuse
because to this day i will still say
mass
mass collection bulk collection of data
that allows for an expedient
identification of a threat to national
security
benefits all of us
but people don't understand
what they want like people don't
understand what the value of their own
privacy is
first of all the fact that people think
they have personal privacy is laughable
you have no privacy the cell phone that
you carry in your pocket you're giving
permission to those apps constantly
you're giving commercial organizations
what you and i have already said are
less tied to ethical responsibility
you're giving them permission to collect
enormous amounts of private data from
you all the time and you know what
happens if at t or verizon sees some
some nefarious activity on your account
they do nothing they might send a note
to fbi because they have to according to
some checklist
but when nsa was collecting intelligence
on metadata from around the united
states they were very specifically
looking for terrorist threats that would
harm american lives
i don't man nsa can clone my phone i
will give them my children's phone i
will give them the passwords to every
one of my accounts if it means that
there's a likelihood that my family will
be safer from a nefarious actor who's
intent on hurting us
nsa doesn't care about your affair nsa
doesn't care if you're cheating on your
taxes nsa doesn't care if you're if you
talk [ __ ] about your boss or if you hate
the u.s president nobody cares about
that your intelligence community is
there to find
threats to national security that's what
they're there to do
what snowden did
when he outed that whole program
the fact that the court the justice
system the civilian justice system went
back and essentially overruled
the ruling of the intelligence courts
before them
just goes to show
how
the general mass community really
shouldn't have a say in what happens in
the intelligence community they really
shouldn't you have
politicians and you have the you have
the opportunity to elect people to a
position and then you trust them that's
what a representative republic is
you vote the people in you trust them to
work on your behalf they make decisions
without running them by you
they make decisions that that that they
believe are in the best interest of
their constituency and that's how our
form of democracy works
it worked we were safer
now that we don't have that information
and now that there's this giant looming
question of whether or not nsa is there
to serve people or is collecting mass
surveillance against all american people
that's not really a true accurate
representation of what they were ever
doing they were looking for the needle
in a haystack of the tre of the series
of transactions in metadata that was
going to lead to american deaths we are
now less secure because they can't do
that and that bothers me
so he said a few really interesting
things there so because you are kind of
an insider war for time an insider
meaning you were able to build up an
intuition about
the the good the bad and the ugly of
these institutions
uh specifically the good a lot of people
don't have a good sense of the good they
know the bad and the ugly
or can infer the bad and the ugly
you mentioned that
the one little
key little thing there at the end
saying the nsa doesn't care
about whether you hate the president or
not
now that's what people really worry
about
is
they they're not sure they can trust the
government to not
uh go into full dictatorial mode
and and uh based on your political
preference your oppositions your
basically one of the essential powers
uh
the freedom of speech in the united
states is ability to criticize your
government exactly and that
they they worry well
can't the government get a hold of the
nsa and start to ask the basic question
well
can you give me a list of people that
are criticizing the government think
about so let's just walk through that
exact example right because this is
it's a preponderance it's a it's a
preponderous fear it's a ridiculous fear
because of
you would have to tap on multiple
elements of government for anything to
happen so for example
let's just say that somebody goes to the
nsa and says hey can you give us a
readout on all the people who are
tweeting terrible things about the
president okay cool here's your 100
million people whatever it is right
here's all the people saying negative
things about the government
so now they have a list what do they do
next well let's just make it simple they
stay with nsa and they say surveil them
even more tap their phones tap their
computers i want to know even more so
then they get this preponderance of
evidence
what do you do with evidence
you take it to a court
well guess what no court is going to
support
anything that goes against
the freedom of speech
so the court is not going to support
what the executive is asking them to do
even before you take somebody to court
you have to involve law enforcement
essentially you have to send some sort
of police force to go apprehend the
individual who's in question
well guess what doesn't meet criteria
for any police force anywhere in the
united states arresting people
who have
who have to say negative things about
the president now if somebody poses a
threat to the life
of a public figure or the threat to life
of a politician that's a completely
different case which means the standards
of evidence are much higher for them to
arrest that person so unless you create
a secret police force then your actual
public police force is never going to
take action so all these people who are
afraid of this this exact situation that
you're outlining they need the creation
of a secret police force the creation of
a secret court that operates outside the
judicial system the creation of a secret
intelligence service that operates
outside of foreign intelligence
collection
all so that a handful of people who
don't like the president
get what whisked away assassinated put
in prison who knows what think about the
resources that would be the amount of
money and time and how hard would it be
to keep that secret to have all of those
things in motion
the reason it worked in in russia and
soviet germany or russia and communist
germany was because everybody knew there
was a secret police everybody knew that
like that there was a threat to work to
speaking out against the government it's
completely different here well so
there's a lot to say so one is yes if i
was a dictator
and i wanted to and just looking at
history
let me let me take myself out of it but
i think one of the more effective ways
is you don't need the surveillance you
can pick out a random person and and in
a public display semi-public display
you know basically put them in jail for
opposing the government whether they
oppose it or not and the fear
that sends a message to a lot of people
that's exactly what you see happening in
china
that's ex what you just light out it's
genius and that is the that is the
standard you don't need the surveillance
for that yep
but that said if you did do the
surveillance
so that's the support the sort of the
incentives aren't aligned it seems like
a lot of work to do for the thing you
could do without the surveillance right
but
you know
yes the courts wouldn't uh if if you
were to be able to get a list of people
which i think that part you could do
correct uh and that opposed the
government you could do that on like
just like you said on twitter publicly
you could make a list
and
with that you can start to especially if
you have a lot of data on those people
find ways in which they did violate the
law
not because they oppose the government
but because in some other way parking
tickets or uh didn't pay the taxes
that's probably a common one or like
screwed up something about the taxes
i just happen to know russia and ukraine
they they're very good at this kind of
stuff that knowing
good how the citizens screwed everything
up because especially in those countries
everybody's breaking the law
because in a corrupt nation you have to
bend the law to operate
like the number of people that pay taxes
fully in those nations is just very low
if not zero and so uh they then used
that breaking of the law to come up with
an excuse to actually put you in jail
based on that
you know so it's possible to imagine but
yes i think
i think that's the ugly part of
surveillance but i do think just like
you said the incentives aren't correct
like you really
don't need to get all of the secret
police and all these kinds of
organizations working if you do have
a charismatic powerful leader that built
up a network that's able to control a
lot of organizations to to a level of
authoritarianism
in a government they're just able to do
the usual thing one have propaganda
machine to tell narratives
to pick out you know uh
people that they can put in jail for
opposing the state
and maybe loud members of the press
start silencing the press there's
there's like a there's a playbook to
this thing right it doesn't require the
surveillance
the surveillance
you know what is useful for the
surveillance is the thing you mentioned
in china which is
encourage everybody
in the citizenry to watch each other to
say there's enemies of the state
everywhere
and then you start having children
reporting on their parents and that kind
of stuff again
don't need a surveillance date for that
now the good of a surveillance system if
it's
operating within ethical bounds is that
yes it could protect the populace so
you're saying like the good
given on your understanding of these
institutions
the good outweighs the bad
absolutely so let me give you just a
practical example so
people don't realize this but there's
multiple surveillance states that are
out there there are surveillance states
that are close allies with the united
states
one of those surveillance states is is
uh the united arab emirates the uae
now i lived in the uae
from 2019 to 2020 uh came back on a
repatriation flight after covet broke
out
and but we were there for a full year we
were we were residents we had ids we had
everything now when you get your
national id in the emirates you get a
chip
and that chip connects you to everything
it connects you to cameras it connects
you to your
license plate on your car to your
passport to your credit card everything
everything is intertwined everything is
interlinked
when you drive there are no police there
are no police on the roads every
50 to 100 meters you cross a camera that
reads your license plate measures your
speed and if you're breaking the speed
limit it just immediately charges your
credit card because it's tied it's all
tied together totally surveillance that
technology was invented by the israelis
who use it in
israel
when i was in abu dhabi and i was
rear-ended at high speed
by what turned out to be an emirati
official a senior ranking official of
one of the emirates
it was caught on camera
his id was registered my id was
registered everything was tied back to
our ids the proof and the evidence was
crystal clear
even still he was emirati i was not so
when i went to the police station to
file the complaint
it was something that nobody was
comfortable with because generally
speaking emiratis don't
don't accept legal claims against their
own from foreigners but the difference
was that i was an american and i was
there on a contract supporting the
emirati government so i had these
different variances right long story
short in the end
the surveillance state is what made sure
that justice was played
because the proof was
was incontrovertible
there was so much evidence collected
because of the surveillance nature of
their state now why do they have a
surveillance state it's not for people
like me it's because they're constantly
afraid of extreme extremist terrorist
activity happening inside abu dhabi are
inside the uae because they're under
constant threat from islam and there are
from from extremists and they're under
constant threat from iran so that's what
drives
the people to want a police state to
want a surveillance state for them
their survival is paramount and they
need the surveillance to have that
survival for us we haven't tasted that
level of of desperation and fear
yet or hopefully never but that's what
makes us feel like there's something
wrong with surveillance
surveillance is all about the purpose
it's all about the intent
well and like like you said companies do
a significant amount of surveillance to
provide us with services that we uh take
for granted for example just um one of
the things
to give props to the digital efforts of
the zielenski administration in ukraine
i don't know if you're aware but they
they have this digital transformation
efforts where you can put like there's
an
it's uh
it's laughable to say in the united
states but they actually did a really
good job of having a government app
that has your passport on it it's all
the digital information you can get a
doctor it's like everything that you
would think america would be doing
uh you know like license like all that
kind of stuff it's in an app you could
pay this payment to each other
and that's all coming i mean there's
probably contractors somehow connected
to the whole thing but that's like under
the flag of government
and so that's an incredible technology
and i didn't i guess hear anybody talk
about surveillance in that context even
though it is but they all love it and
it's super easy and they
frankly already it's so easy and
convenient they've already taken for
granted that of course this is what you
do of course your passport is on your
phone yeah for everybody to have yeah
housed on a server that you have no idea
where it's at that could be hacked at
any time by a third party
they don't ask these kinds of questions
because it's so convenient as we do for
uh
for
google
facebook twitter
uh apple microsoft um
products we use security and convenience
are on two opposite sides of another
spectrum yeah the more convenient
something is the less secure and the
more secure something is the less
convenient
and that's a that's a battle that we're
always
we're always working with as individuals
and then we're trying to outsource that
battle to our politicians and our
politicians are frankly just more
interested in being politicians
you